this is his theater and united's leading
man is back on the stage
[Applause]
to have cut manchester city out of the
chase for ronaldo makes it the sweetest
signing i live in legend so
everyone is just hyped over him like
even if someone doesn't watch football
knows who's ronaldo it's going to be
surreal for him but it's going to be
thrilled for
a couple of generations of supporters
you know who are there first time around
probably the best transfer window i've
seen since i've been a united fan of the
event how disappointed would you be if
you don't win a trophy this season oh
massively and i thought he would hit it
but he could potentially be in a lot of
trouble if we don't win a trophy this
season it started one night in lisbon
back in 2003 when united played sporting
the teenager was so good that alex
ferguson had decided by half time that
he had to sign him
having won pretty much everything since
with real madrid juventus and portugal
he returns to manchester age 36. i'm
ready and i think i will be a huge thing
in the last i know everybody four years
shirt sales have already broken records
but he steps back into a club but just
last may the anger towards the owners
the glazer family boiled over
the glazers remain but the club isn't
just signing big players we wouldn't
rely
just on cristiano to be able to create
that fan sentiment i think we've put a
lot of time in with our fans certainly
over the last six to nine months
listening to what they're saying and
revisiting what the fans forum discusses
setting up a new advisory board we're
also looking to put a fancier scheme in
so i think all of that together as
meaning has meant i think that we're
starting to really reset that
relationship gives manchester united's
number seven his introduction to life at
all traffic
here comes
young ronaldo his first debut was as a
substitute now the older ronaldo has
very little left to prove
but he's not just here for the adulation
cristiano ronaldo is now front and
center and of all of the great number
sevens that have graced this stadium
george best eric cantona david beckham
none of them have made a comeback still
at the very top of their game
a three o'clock saturday afternoon
kickoff against newcastle means it won't
be shown live in the uk
but whatever role cristiano ronaldo
plays
the encore in his theater
starts now
tom parmenter sky news old trafford